from Tel Aviv the former British army
officer and now Trustee of the UK
Friends of the association for the
well-being of Israeli soldiers Colonel
Richard Kemp and from romala Palestinian
national initiative leader Mustafa bouti
thank you both for joining me let me
start with you if I may Mr barouti uh
we've just had this news in we've all
just heard it of the Deputy head of
hamaz being killed in Beirut obviously
this is the leader of the group that
killed Palestinians in the K in Gaza in
20 6 to 7 and of course one of the
people who planned the October the 7th
Massacre what's your response to his
killing
tonight well if you allow me and I hope
you will accept that from me I think
your presentation is absolutely
one-sided totally biased to the Israeli
side you speak about the right of Israel
to defend itself but you don't mention
the right of the Palestinian people to
defend themselves you failed to mention
that Israel is the aggress
which started this terrible occupation
since 56 years and Palestinians as
people under occupation according to
international law have the right to
defend themselves and to resist
occupation you you failed to mention
that no less than 29,000 civilian
Palestinians have been killed by Israeli
BB I mentioned that I mentioned that
including in no no you mentioned as if
they were killed on their own not by
Israeli bombardment what should be clear
here is that 29,000 Palestinians if we
include those under the rebel have been
killed by Israeli terrible air strikes
and artillery bombardment including no
less than 12,000 children I've said so
many times on so many programs I'm
against the killing of any civilian
whether Palestinian or Israel but if you
speak about the killing of 30 Israeli
children you should also speak about the
12,000 Palestinian children who were
killed well
Mr May uh I did mention the killing of
children I did say that that is
appalling damage in the war but let me
let me finish the question before you
try to answer a question I haven't yet
asked you said that the Palestinian
people allowed to uh resist as you call
it what what does that look like in your
view according to international law
people who are under occupation have the
right to resist in all forms including
military forms as long as they respect
international law and international
humanitarian law okay so what does it
look like does it Israel Israel wants
not only to look I've been struggling
with nonviolent resistance all my life I
was injured nine times by the Israeli
Army although I never used any weapon I
was shot I was shot twice but but you're
not telling but you're telling me sir
wait a minute you're not telling me what
legitimate resistance is while
legitimate resistance is all forms of
resistance that respect International
humanitarian law which means not
attacking civilians not attacking
children it's very clear that's what
international law says I not creating
that okay but even when I was in my
white coat wait a minute when I was in
my white coat in treating an injured
person an Israeli sniper shot me twice
the same same mentality of these snipers
killed Shireen Abu your colleague the
journalist and nobody no Israeli was
indicted 33 of my Pro my colleagues
doctors nurses health professionals have
been killed by Israeli air strikes in
Gaza 104 ambulances were destroyed all
our health centers were destroyed this
is not acceptable okay thank you mrti Mr
baruti we have another guest so I'd like
to go over to Tel Aviv to Colonel
Richard Kemp what do you make of what
you've just
heard well I think um Mr barouti talks
about uh legitimate resistance adhering
to the laws of War uh well first of all
resistance to war what the the Israelis
withdrew from Gaza in
2005 uh and set effectively set up a two
State solution let let the Palestinian
Authority which was then taken over by
Hamas run their own territory so what
are they actually resisting what's this
resistance about and when it comes to
the laws of war the people the Hamas
butchers that Mr barouti has been quoted
as referring to as our brave Fighters
they went into Israeli territory on the
7th of October they raped burnt alive
butchered cut off their heads kidnapped
abused civilians and soldiers civilians
though which is you know against
obviously it's against any law of War it
was against the laws of war to kill
anyone inside another country but in in
that way but but to do to to to butcher
civilians like that what where's the
laws of war there and secondly ever
since that day and of course many many
times before his Brave Hamas Fighters as
he calls them have been firing rockets
indiscriminately at civilian populations
inside Israel and they're still doing so
they won't be doing so much longer
because they're about to be throttled by
the IDF and not only that but they've
also been firing them from within the
civilian population that is against the
laws of armed conflict and preventing
civilians from leaving the combat areas
when the igf are trying to warn them
about attacks again against the laws of
arm conflict they've also fired many of
their Rockets into the Gaza civilian
population we just have to look at the
Al Ali Hospital attack that was
attributed to the IDF but turned out to
be an Islamic Jihad and other Brave
Islamic Jihad Fighters firing their own
Rockets into their own civilian
population let's not forget what Hamas
is all about here the the reason Hamas
launched this attack there are strategic
reasons of course but the the overriding
reason they launched this attack on the
7th of October and the reason they
launched all of their attacks is to
force Israel to defend itself from these
attacks which any country and every
country would do and has the right and
the obligation to do and in in carrying
out its reaction to these attacks Israel
unfortunately has no choice but to to
kill innocent civilians in the process
despite the efforts they take which are
enormous to avoid doing that but that's
what Hamas wants Hamas they don't they
don't just want civilians to protect
their terrorists they want Israel to
kill civilians so that Israel is then
condemned delegitimized vilified
isolated around the world and it happen
works every time in the United Nations
the
universities uh in in some governments
human rights groups always condemn
Israel that's what Hamas want and that
encourages Hamas to do it again and
again and again and by Mr barouti who
who claims to support peaceful
resistance by Mr barouti justifying what
they do he also has blood on his hands
from
encouraging get a moment Mr V you're
going to get a moment to respond to that
I I just want to ask you first let's
just clear that this up before you do
respond to Colonel Kemp did you call him
as our brave Fighters or
not I never said that no I don't know
where you got that from no it's not true
you are putting words in my mouth but
let me let me respond to what the
colonal said the colonialist said is
reflecting clearly a very clear white
supremacy approach it is okay Supremacy
why don't you say why don't you say why
don't you say clearly that you are
supporting the killing of Palestinian
children why don't you say clearly that
you are supporting the killing of
Palestinian civilians why don't you say
that you are supporting Israeli
occupation of Palestinian land and
supporting three terrible war crimes
even the American public is against that
three war crimes the war crime of
genocide which the international court
of justice is looking into now the war
crime of collective punishment and the
war crime of ethnic cleansing 90 wait a
minute 90% of the Palestinian people
were eved from their homes what would
you have said if Palestinians eved
Israelis from their homes that be
acceptable they have done why don't you
use the same standard I'm going to go
back I'm going to go back to colel k a
moment but why why is why is this white
supremacy where did that come from the
Israeli public are not all white because
I don't I think you don't see us white
enough and you are against anybody who's
not white and that's why you justify
terrible atrocities that Israel is
committing and you are justifying not
only the fact that Israel is occupying
us but the fact that Israel conducted
the worst kind of ethnic cleansing in
1948 forcing 70% of the Palestinian
people out I'm going to go back to col
facts I'll just go back to Colonel Kemp
quickly Colonel Kemp you you said that
he that Mr vgy said our brave Fighters
were hamz he says he didn't say that um
who's
right well I certainly read him quote he
may not have said it but I read him
being quoted as saying I think it was
Middle East eye or something like that
but he can certainly if he'd like to
Google it to see what he actually said
he can find that on the internet and
what do you make of this claim and what
do you make of this claim Colonel Kemp
that everyone who justifies always in
any way on the side of his during this
war is a is a white supremacist because
Israel doesn't look like a very allwhite
country to me but I don't
know no I mean you know there's there
are all blends of um races in Israel and
one thing we should remember as well is
that there is a significant Muslim Arab
population in Israel and one thing that
I've observed in recent weeks ised a
skyring a skyrocketing of support for
Israel among the Israeli Arab Muslim
population the the poll polls number of
polls have shown that a huge grow growth
of support for Israel a greater
association with the state of Israel
since the 7th of October and that is
partly due to the fact that Hamas his
his Brave fighters from Hamas that that
he clearly supports came in and um and
butchered not just uh Israelis but
Israeli Jews but they also came and and
killed a number of Arabs and and and
people from many different ethnicities
so what he's talking I think it's a
great throwaway line white supremacy it
obviously gets you know it's one of
these intersectional terms you know me
too and all this sort of stuff it's it's
he obviously thinks that's going to
Garner support for him for people who uh
you know do object rightly object to the
idea of white supremacy but I don't
think that comes into this argument one
little bit Mr margi finally we've
already got a few seconds but you said
we need to go back to 1947 and 1948
what do you say to the people who say
you can go back thousands of years and
you never never have an end to this
argument well look Palestinians were
displaced from their country including
cities like jafa where my father lived
and haa and AKA 75 years ago if Israel
is after 3,000 years have the right to
go back and demand to be in Palestine
then why not Palestinians who have been
evicted 75 years ago why should we
forget about our own country and let's
go back to the United Nations resolution
that established the state of Israel it
said that there should be two states
Israel and Palestine Israel was created
and Palestine was occupied that is the
reality as we all know Mr Mari there's
one thing we can be sure about about
that that's highly disputed history as
it all is there wasn't a Palestinian
State then there could have been it's
the United Nation resolution it's a it's
a very sad thing there wasn't a
Palestinian State created then and that
the Palestinians it will be it will be I
assure you a lot of people hope it will
be but uh if there certainly won't be if
people are praising hamz and uh the
longer they're around the less likely it
is there will ever be a Palestinian
State as far as I can see but thank you
very much Colonel Richard Kemp in Tel
Aviv and thank you uh to masafa bouti
our intersectionalist tonight in
rala